let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right remember when we were told
that the rioting in portland
was all in response to the presence of
federal agents even though it started
before the federal agents got there
it was still because of them somehow it
was their fault and that as soon as they
left the rioting would go away that's
what we were told
of course
many problems with that logic from the
beginning you would have to have the iq
of
a spatula to i believed it to begin with
but um if you do have the iq
of a of a kitchen utensil and you
actually believed that the writing would
stop because law enforcement
left then this footage will be very
shocking to you watch
[Music]
well you can see there that's that's
rioters in portland
after feds had already left trying to
burn down a police precinct
so i i not very peaceful
not very peaceful um that's not not
exactly
joining hands around a campfire singing
kumbaya now there was a fire but
it wasn't a campfire so uh no i i
i think it it turns out that when you
have
a lawless mob of criminals
and you do less to enforce the law
you end up with more crime crazy crazy
how that works
really shocking number two we begin um
or not again we
we go now to a news story this is a new
story
that doesn't really exist i guess the
news here is that there is
not any news um and i think in this case
the fact that there is no news is news
indeed i'm starting to confuse myself
now
here's what i'm talking about you may
remember the story from about six weeks
ago a woman by the name of althea
bernstein
in madison wisconsin called the police
late at night claiming that she had just
been attacked by a gang of racist white
men
and she said that this roving gang of
white supremacists they were all wearing
hawaiian
shirts they were like frat boys she said
they came to her at
a stop light they sprayed her in the
face with
lighter fluid and then they threw a
lighter into her car
and set her on fire her face was
actually
on fire that's what she said now this
was huge news when it happened it was
reported everywhere i heard it all over
the place
meghan markle even reached out to
bernstein to express her
condolences it was a
a a pretty big deal and sure
i mean if something like that happens of
course it's a big deal you've got a
group of murderous bigots patrolling the
streets of an american city
literally trying to burn women alive in
the middle of the street
that's a big deal but then and this
brings us to our
update today um
then there was nothing that was six
weeks ago
and it was a big story for a few days
and then it just disappeared
madison police said they were
investigating the attack then the feds
got involved and
um you know this is all good because it
happened
at an intersection in a major city so
there has to be cameras all over the
place and witnesses
surely these flame throwing races are on
tape
someone else must have seen them also i
mean it should be pretty easy to track
them down
yet six weeks later we've heard nothing
about this case
nothing not a word hmm
it really makes you think in fact i went
to google and i searched for althea
althea bernstein i searched her name
story news stories from the last week
zero zero reporting not
one story on the entire internet
was published in the last week about
this case isn't that pretty strange i
mean it's almost like this story
vanished into thin air
and so did the white boys with the
lighter fluid and the lighter that
somehow could stay lit when they threw
it
now let's just imagine crazy thought
crazy thought but let's just thought
experiment
let's imagine that possibly the white
boys vanished into thin air because
and nobody ever noticed them except for
her
uh and they weren't recorded by any
camera as far as we know
let's imagine again hypothetically that
all of that is the case
because they don't exist pretty easy to
vanish when you never existed to begin
with
so let's say wild theory none of this
ever happened
it's yet another hate crime hoax on that
theory the cops would would of course
know that it's bs and they would know
right away i mean they would know
probably from the moment they hear it
but all they'd have to do is look at the
surrounding video footage
talk to some people that were in the
area and they would know right away this
just this
simply didn't happen
and yet i mean again on this theory
they're just
not saying anything about it
hoping we all forget and the sad thing
is
that plan seems to actually be working
just fine
but it's scary to think that we've
arrived at this point where a person can
invent a hate crime
file a false police report and just get
away with it
no penalty whatsoever because the police
are too afraid to tell the public that
it was all a load of horse manure
that's a scary thought number three um
you know i have to throw this in here
credit words do uh i uh i am capable of
of
you know of giving credit sometimes i
mean i
you know that i i criticize trump
sometimes and i especially criticize
his tweeting uh but sometimes i have to
admit even
that he puts out one hell of a great
tweet
and this is one of those times so like i
said credit word so i just want to show
you this tweet because i thought it was
so good
and i really just i wanted to give all
the credit to donald trump on this one
um here's the tweet for me he says uh
look at this
here's the here's the quote he says um
cities across the nation that are run by
democrats are in shambles
matt walsh yeah he seems to be quoting
someone there someone
someone who was on tucker last night he
was watching tucker and he was quoting
i don't know i'm not sure who that guy
is really but brilliant point
that man whoever that is i think we can
all agree has
the powers of insight that would rival
aristotle
um so a great job by trump putting that
that quote out there that's all i want
really like i said this is really about
giving donald trump credit
for a great tweet number four it was
just announced that uh
the live adaptation of mulan will go
straight to disney's
streaming service and uh right when
you're done after you're
done watching black as king you can go
and watch mulan
except it's gonna cost you thirty
dollars it's gonna come out in a few
weeks
thirty dollars plus the subscriptions
you pay for the subscription at disney
plus and they're gonna charge you an
extra 30 bucks to see this
and this is all i'm gonna say if you pay
thirty dollars to watch a lifeless
pointless rehashed remake of a disney
cartoon that you've already seen
i don't think it's too much to
suggest that you should lose your
citizenship rights
and i don't even say that ironically i i
would with all sincerity
support a policy that stripped you of
your constitutional rights all of them
for paying 30
to watch the mulan remake
five um just a policy proposal i'm
throwing out there if any if anyone
wants to run with it number five finally
oprah winfrey who we should note
is worth two billion dollars spoke out
this week against the scourge of white
privilege
um oprah with her two billion dollars is
very concerned
that white people in trailer parks
wearing goodwill hand-me-downs
might be a little bit too privileged and
here's part of her discussion
on that subject there are white people
who are not as powerful
as the system of white people the caste
system that's
been put in place but they still
no matter where they are on the wrong
or the ladder of success they still have
their whiteness
i just love how she's having this
discussion about white privilege
while sitting in a room that looks like
that room from the last matrix film
she's literally controlling the whole
matrix from that room
and yet complaining about other people
having privilege this
this is weapons grade irony right here
i i really know what i really like to
imagine is her
shouting something like white people are
too privileged and then
walking directly into her 98 room
mansion
tossing her 40 000 coat made of the
skins of albino seals
at her butler you know petting her
siberian tiger
and then just heading to her golden
crusted bathtub filled with champagne
and caviar and jumping in
um that's how i imagine that oprah
winfrey must live
but yeah you know really really rick and
maureen
down the street driving their minivan to
home depot on a saturday stopping at
ruby tuesdays for their
uh early afternoon special on the way
back those are the people that are
privileged not oprah winfrey
those people sure yeah we make a joke
out of it but
this it's because it is a joke you see
the farce that this
that this white privilege concept uh
has become that now even
the richest woman in america uh one of
the richest in the world
is complaining about other people having
privilege
it's just fantastic hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated